hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skin care nerd
and pimply person when i was a teenager
i assumed i'd grow out of it and i'd be
pimple-free by my 30s
but that was a lie but there have been a
lot of really good products that have
come out for treating pimples that i
really wish i had in my teens
and one of the brands i've been using a
lot is zit sticker they make these
really neat stickers for targeting spots
and i'm going to talk you through my
favorite products and the science behind
how they work
this video is sponsored by zit sticker
but these are my honest opinions of the
products after i've been using them for
a while
i've been using the killer patches for a
bit over a year the hyper fade patches
for a few months
and the goo getter only for a few weeks
but that's because this is their latest
launch
if you like noting out about the science
behind beauty products click the like
the subscribe and the notification bell
so you don't miss any videos
let's start with the killer patches
these are micro dart patches that are
designed for pimples that are a bit too
deep for regular topical spot treatments
to get to
they have a chip with tiny spikes or
darts as they're officially called and
this is stuck to a hydrocolloid bandage
the darts have active ingredients in
them and when you put it on your skin
the darts sink a little bit into your
skin
and then they dissolve and that delivers
the active ingredients deeper into your
skin
closer to where they need to be to deal
with the pimple the killer kit has two
parts it has the cleaner cleansing wipes
and the killer patches
you clean the area first with the
cleaner wipe and that gets rid of oil
and dirt and so the patch sticks down
better this also has actives in it that
can help with the pimples so it's got
salicylic acid and tea tree oil and
these can clear out the pore
and help calm down the pimple after
wiping you stick on the patch with the
dark side down
the darts dissolve within about two
hours and that delivers the actives
so the actors in this they're salicylic
acid again also hyaluronic acid which is
a really great humectant moisturizer
oligopeptide 76 which is an
antimicrobial peptide that's
non-irritating
and niacinamide which helps with uneven
skin tone obvious pores and redness
so the darts will dissolve within about
two hours but it's better to leave the
patch on for longer so i usually put
this on overnight
so leaving the patch on there actually
helps the active ingredients absorb
better
there's a thing where if you occlude
your skin if you cover it up with
something
then active ingredients can get in more
easily the patch also protects the area
so you don't pick at it as much
and it stays clean the patch also keeps
the area moist which is better for
healing
i like using these patches on medium
depth pimples so not the ones that are
like
really hard lumps but the ones that are
a bit shallower
a little bit smaller but they're really
red and angry these ones usually take a
few days before you can start to see the
pass
but i found that if you put this on
early enough the bump
sort of goes backwards with any pimple
that has puffs in it i like to put on a
hydrocolloid bandage
these are the pimple patches that you
might have seen around they usually come
on a sheet and you
peel it off and stick it on a pimple so
the sticky side has a humectant in it
and that
sucks up any fluid from a pimple they
also protect your pimples from dirt
and they stop you from picking at them
also if they soak up enough fluid you
get this really satisfying white spot
zit sticker have just launched the goo
get a spot clarifying dots
these are hydrocolloid bandages but
unlike a lot of the other ones on the
market they also have actives in them
like with the killer patches we have
salicylic acid and tea tree oil and
these clear out the clogs and calm down
the pimple
there's also niacinamide that's soothing
and helps with uneven skin tone
on top of that there's also vitamin c in
the form of ascorbic acid
this is an antioxidant that helps shield
against free radical damage
and it also helps keep your skin tone
even as the pimple heals
again we have that occlusion effect when
you cover up your skin it absorbs
ingredients better
even if you don't have anything like
micro darts and so
having that hydrocolloid combined with
the active ingredients it's a really
effective option
there's no cleaning wipe with the goo
getter but because it sits on top of the
skin rather than sinking in
then it doesn't really need it as much
you should still make sure that you
clean the skin first though so you don't
trap any dirt in there
also make sure your skin is dry before
you apply these products otherwise the
darts on the killer patch are just going
to dissolve on top of your skin
and the goo getter probably won't stick
it might absorb out some of the water
and so it's not absorbing the fluid
inside your pimple the goo getter
patches are a bit on the smaller side
so they're good for small pimples but if
you have a lot of fluid
these probably won't work as well i'm
hoping that zit sticker will also follow
up with bigger ones too
finally there's also hyperfade this is a
micro dart patch that targets the dark
spot that's left after your pimple goes
away
like with a lot of other asians i'm
really prone to hyperpigmentation after
pimples
so it's really good to see products that
cater for this hyperfade uses the same
hyaluronic acid based dart technology as
the killer patches but there are fading
ingredients in this instead
so there's kojic acid niacinamide
vitamin c
butane tranexamic acid and licorice root
extract
i've been using these on my dark acne
marks and they've been working really
well
i've always had a lot of success with
fading dark acne marks using ascorbic
acid vitamin c
so i'm not really surprised that these
patches work so well
they have the ascorbic acid and lots of
other stuff so they have the extra
active ingredients they have the darts
and they have the occlusion so i hope
you liked this video if you did you can
give it a thumbs up and subscribe
you can also follow me on instagram at
lab muffin beauty science and check out
my blog for more about the science
behind beauty products
see you next time to nerd out more
you